xavier breton merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre
ce premier ministre la deuxième année
consécutive la natalité baisse dans
notre pays les chiffres publiés hier par
l'insee sont inquiétants très inquiétant
il y a eu en 2016 une baisse de 14 mille
naissances après une diminution de 20
mille l'année précédente
le taux de fécondité à lui chuté de 2
enfants par femme à 1,93 et le solde
naturel de la population c'est-à-dire la
différence entre les naissances et les
décès est au niveau le plus bas depuis
40 ans le signal d'alarmé désormais
tirer le renouvellement des générations
n'est plus assurée dans notre pays et la
confiance des familles et briser ce
triste résultat est le bilan de la
politique anti famille de ce quinquennat
durant cinq ans les familles surtout les
familles des classes moyennes ont été
malmenés
notre politique familiale qui pourtant
faisait consensus depuis la libération
était remise en cause dans ses
fondements mais les familles hôtes asie
subi par deux fois la baisse du quotient
familial ainsi que la fin de
l'universalité des allocations
familiales
et ne cherchez pas nous faire croire que
les économies faites sur le dos de ces
familles ont été redistribués à d'autres
plus modestes c'est faux car ce sont
bien toutes les familles qui ont été
touchés toucher ainsi par la baisse de
la page la prestation d'accueil du jeune
enfant
selon l'unaf se sont même 160 mille
familles vivant sous le seuil de
pauvreté qui sont perdantes
avec les baisses de cette page ou de la
prime de naissance il s'agit donc bien
d'une baisse importante des aides aux
familles et pour la première fois depuis
1945 les familles ne savent plus si
elles peuvent compter sur le soutien de
la solidarité nationale pour élever
leurs enfants
les coupes successives dans le budget de
la politique familiale ont brisé cette
confiance alors monsieur le premier
ministre
regrettez-vous le bilan de la politique
anti famille mené depuis cinq ans la
parole est à madame laurence rossignol
ministre dé famille de l'enfance et des
droits des femmes
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
xavier breton
quelle aubaine d'un certain point de vue
trois centièmes de points de baisse de
la natalité en pleine période électorale
quelle aubaine pour accuser un
gouvernement d'être responsable qu'ils
soient nés cette année trente mille
bébés en moins et accusé une politique
familiale sur laquelle c'est vrai nous
ne sommes pas d'accord et d'or en effet
les modulations des allocations
familiales à diminuer les allocations
familiales de moins de 10% des familles
les ménages les plus aisés ont
effectivement été appelés à contribuer
ceux qui gagnent plus de 6000 euros net
par mois ont effectivement vu leurs
prestations familiales baisser un peu de
façon à augmenter les allocations
familiales des familles monoparentales
des familles nombreuses
augmenter l'allocation de rentrée
scolaire tout ce qui permet d'avoir une
politique familiale plus juste et plus
redistributive
et en ce qui concerne la baisse de la
natalité comment vous dire
aujourd'hui les femmes de 25 à 29 ans
retarde l'âge de leur premier enfant
aujourd'hui vous moi tous les parents
conseillons à nos enfants d'avoir
d'abord un métier une situation
professionnelle et un couple stable
avant de faire un enfant est en effet
les jeunes rentrent plus tardivement
dans une vie professionnelle stable
c'est une des principales raisons de ces
trois centièmes de points de baisse de
l'intensité mais je vais vous rassurer
monsieur breton
néanmoins nous restons les champions de
la natalité de toute l'europe et de tous
les pays similaires à un autre en grande
bretagne le taux de natalité est
inférieur et il a chuté brutalement au
cours des dernières années
aucun autre pays à part l'irlande avec
lesquels nous sommes au même point n'a
le même taux de natalité que le nôtre
l'exception française en maternelle est
alité et la grâce à une politique
familiale de soutien à l'activité
professionnelle des femmes et aux
nombreuses places d'accueil aux jeunes
enfants que nous avons ouvert pendant ce
quinquennat remet